Hallar la pendiente de una línea que está
dibujada en esta gráfica.
Así que la pendiente de una línea, está
definida como lo que se eleva, ajá, entre,
lo que corremos digamos o también lo puedes
ver como el cambio en "y" entre...
entre el cambio... cambio en "x"
Y déjenme mostrarles lo que esto significa,
así que vamos a empezar con un punto arbitrario
en esta línea y están, digamos seleccionados
o resaltados con puntos gordos,
así que si queremos empezar en este punto,
digamos que queremos hallar cual es nuestro
cambio en "x" en la dirección positiva, ajá,
queremos ir de este punto a este otro punto, ok.
¿Cuánto nos movemos en "x"?
Así que si nos movemos en "x", digamos hacia
la derecha, estamos yendo desde -3 a 0,
así que vamos desde -3 a 0, ok, así que nuestro
cambio en "x" y éste es delta "x",
nuestro delta "x" es igual a 3,
aquí el cambio en "x"es 3.
Y ahora, ¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "y",
si nuestro cambio en "x" fue 3?
Ok bueno, pues nos movemos... ehhh... si nos
movimos 3 en "x" a la derecha,
¿cuánto nos movemos en "y"?
Bueno, pues nos movimos hacia abajo, fuimos
de 3 a 2, así que hicimos 1 cambio en "y",
hacia abajo, así que nuestro cambio es -1,
ok...
Tuvimos una...
Digamos que el cambio en "y" fue -1, ok, y
el cambio en "x"fue igual a 3, my bien.
Entonces al final, lo que fue la pendiente,
nuestra pendiente fue -1/3...
déjenme ponerlo con este...
déjenme moverlo...
Entonces la pendiente fue -1/3.
Y lo que quiero hacer ahora es mostrarles,
que la pendiente no depende de la elección de los 2 puntos que me tomé.
Por ejemplo, vámonos ahora a ir de este otro punto de abajo y movernos hacia atrás al punto de arriba, ok.
Entonces, si voy de este punto al punto más
alto, ¿cuál fue nuestro cambio en "x"?
Bueno, nuestro cambio en "x" es todo esto,
ajá, es toda esta distancia de aquí y nuestro
cambio en "x" es ir de 3 a -3 y nos fuimos en
6 unidades pero hacia atrás,
así que nuestro cambio en "x" fue -6, ok,
delta "x" en este caso es -6.
Ahora, si delta "x" es -6 y regresamos a este
punto inicial,
¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "y" para llegar a ese punto?
Entonces bueno, estábamos en "y" igual a
1 y subimos hasta "y" igual a 3, por lo tanto,
este cambio fue positivo, porque subimos,
ajá, y fue un cambio de 2 unidades.
Así que delta "y" es igual a 2, ok.
La pendiente es el cambio de "y" entre el
cambio de "x", ¿correcto?
Entonces nuestro cambio en "y"
simplemente fue... ehhh...
cuanto subimos o bajamos en la dirección vertical,
nuestro cambio en "x" es cuanto nos movimos
en la dirección horizontal y la pendiente
nos queda 2 entre -6, que es también, -1/3.
Y podrías verificarlo tú mismo, tómate
ahora estos dos puntos, empieza en cualquiera de estos,
digamos en éste y ehhh, llegas a este último punto.
Así que para cualquier línea...
Déjenme hacerlo de nuevo, tenemos aquí un
cambio en "x", en este caso nos movimos 3
en la dirección positiva, así que tenemos
el cambio en "x" igual a 3
y el cambio en "y" fue negativo verdad, bajamos, tenemos un cambio en "y" de -1, porque bajamos.
Así que la pendiente, nuevamente, es -1/3.